I try to explain what i'm capable of but we
don't have the million years it would take
for you to understand some i guess cultural
pop references were of course the wizard of oz
sunset boulevard citizen kane uh willy wonka and
chocolate factory the archetype of the wizard and
what happens to him when he gets bored you know
and he becomes a trickster guys if i was gonna
do an exploding chair why wouldn't i just do
an exploding floor and i think when we meet he
who remains he's on the borderline of those two
things you don't really know where he's at and i
think the ambiguity of that is one of the wicked
things about it you think i'm just here with you
i am everywhere like we're watching the flowering
of the next phase of the marvel universe
the variant of he who remains the one he's been
talking about the one that he's so afraid of
is kang kang is bent on destruction and
i'm so curious to see what jonathan does
in the future i think with he who
remains the the objective for me
was to give me the largest canvas possible and
then from that as kang begins to wear his head and
do his deeds in so many ways he has no choice
but to be in opposition or to be different from
he who remains Welcome back everyone this
is going to be my brand new loki kang video
there were a whole bunch of deleted scenes that
they just released so we'll break it all down
obviously jonathan major is talking a lot about
the different versions of him and distinguishing
between the he who remains version that we saw and
the king the conqueror version that we're going to
see during ant-man 3 quantumania and it seems
like during loki season 2. so if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos and careful for spoilers from the
loki series if you haven't seen those episodes yet
because this is obviously jonathan majors and tom
hiddleston the other production crew the marvel
executives talking a lot about king the conquer
in what's going on with his future in the mcu so
biggest thing here obviously i think is that they
clarify which version of kang loki is looking at
that statue at the tva or the version of the tva
that he goes back to saying that that is supposed
to be the true version of kang the conqueror
the version that he's probably going to be playing
during ant-man 3 quantumania and i love how
jonathan majors talks about how that kang is going
to be like the antithesis of he who remains king
making him sound super hardcore like he says that
that version can't help but be the opposite of
he who remains given the way that they all exist
in the multiverse like they're all in opposition
so all the different versions of kang are supposed
to feel very different and they will when they
show up like they'll do all the different comic
book versions of king like scarlet centurion
rama tud eventually but all in different ways
but eventually you do have to have like a main
alternate version of kang who was supposed to be
the worst like the darkest timeline version of
king in the way they talk about him the way that
jonathan majors talks about king the conqueror
this statue in the tva it sounds like that's
who this is going to be so it's not just that
another version of kang seems like he's winning
the multiversal war that looks like kang from the
comics is the worst version of kang seems like
he won the multiversal war or is in the process
of winning it at least the way mobius and hunter
b15 are shouting about the 63 branching timelines
going past redline at the end of the episode
just makes it sound like the multiverse war
still might be in the process of happening when
loki comes back like all is not completely lost
but it definitely seems like all might be lost and
that's the big cliffhanger like how do we fix this
during season two and in the other marvel movies
where they deal with the kang character or king
variants the way he spoke about the history of the
multiverse war during the actual episode he says
the key to him winning the first war was goliath
so in the new multiverse war as it's playing out
whereas it seems like it's in the middle of
playing out when this true king the conqueror
version is resurrected so to speak like the way
he who remains talks about resurrection maybe he
winds up doing something differently when their
timelines all reset that gives him an advantage
over he who remains in the second time around but
then in some of the deleted scenes he talks about
how he's not just in the room with them here he's
everywhere that's both a reference to his variance
he's metaphorically and literally everywhere in
the multiverse but it's also a reference to the
way he spent millions of years traveling through
time and manipulating time to create and maintain
the sacred timeline his own personal timeline so
if you could see in the fourth dimension you'd see
him up and down the timeline all over the place
at different points in history that's also a big
easter egg for kang in the comics working with
other versions of himself across the timeline
past present and future banding together to
control all of time in a sort of pyramid scheme
but it's not a multiverse story it's just a
single timeline and it's just versions of him
from his future and his past working together
obviously that's a little bit different in the
mcu they're going with more of a multiverse
variance approach where you do have versions
of kang banding together forming councils of
kangs but it's from different timelines it's not
from the same timeline like each own kang is the
conqueror of his own timeline in a way i do like
that jonathan magers mentions willy wonka in the
chocolate factory as one of the inspirations for
this version of kang he who remains the
older immortus version of the character
i mentioned that a couple times during
my loki finale video just because he's a
character here at the end of his story who's
grown tired of his life's mission this grand
plan that he's had and wants to pass on his
responsibilities to a worthy successor so
that he can either die or retire or in the case of
the loki series with this he who remains character
kind of both if it wasn't clear why it seemed
like he didn't care either way what happened to
him it was just because he'd grown tired of what
he'd been doing for millions and millions of years
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs all over the
citadel at the end of time too inside with the
artifacts that he has the design language they go
into that in pretty great detail as well even the
costume that he wears is meant to be like a big
walking easter egg like he mentions that he gets
all of his clothing pieces from different points
in history he who remains lived forever you know
and one of the great things i got to experience
with our costume designer is that every piece we
decided was from a different place the cape i had
on was from the victoria era the shoes are from
genghis khan the the pants from mongolia etc
you know you just mix and match it together and
it informs the character i think that it
will be talked about for a long time dancing
there's also the deleted scene of him talking
about it taking millions of years to explain
himself fully to loki and sylvie he's not lying he
does give them the epic cliffs notes version speed
running his personal history and the true history
of the multiverse they also talk a lot about the
wizard of oz during this how they use that as a
guiding metaphor for forming the concept of the
character someone who is the driving force of the
story looming large over all the characters and
then they repeat the line finding the man behind
the curtain in the idea that you're supposed to
have this really big surprise when loki and
sylvie find the character like someone that
you completely were not expecting the way they
actually talk about the design of the citadel
though they said it's supposed to feel like
a combination of hearst castle xanadu this
palatial estate to make a real world comparison
this huge monstrosity of a personal project
that he who remains created over thousands and
thousands of years that eventually just abandoned
in his boredom like the castle is supposed to
isolate him protect him from his variants that
could potentially rise up should one have broken
free from a branch timeline over the millions of
years that he's been here so in addition to miss
minutes and eliath there are meant to be a lot of
defensive measures that he built into the citadel
itself that you don't really see here because it's
fallen into so much disrepair but it's a citadel
because it was meant to defend him during the
multiverse war when it was still happening before
but the interesting thing though is that a lot of
the rubble that you see around the citadel inside
when they're walking around when they first walk
through the entryway it isn't from battle damage
it's just because over the millions of years
he who remains king has allowed it to fall into
disrepair like he literally just does not care
about anything anymore he just completely
retreated up to the upper levels in his office
so when they're talking about some of the other
inspirations for what was going on here at the
end of time with the citadel they also said that
they use gray gardens like this once great estate
has since turned into this decrepit version
of itself because its owner has turned into
a bit of a hermit retreating to the upper levels
over millions of years and he just refuses to fix
all the stuff that's breaking down at the lower
levels the other interesting detail here too is
that the production designer would not clarify if
the forced timekeeper statue was broken because it
fall into disrepair like the rest of the castle or
if he who remains kang had destroyed it himself or
if it was damaged from one of the other previous
loki's that they hint at that had made his way
to the castle to be tested if he was worthy to
take over but the whole thing with that fourth
timekeeper statue is the production designer said
that they weren't allowed to speak about it in
general just because marvel would be covering that
in an upcoming story but they didn't say if that'd
be loki season 2 ant-man 3 or some other project
but i'm assuming they're going to save it for loki
season two i talked a little about it in my loki
finale video in the comics there was a fourth time
keeper called the oracle of siwa who was banished
by he who remains from the comics to ancient egypt
and he helped the fantastic four fight another
different time travel villain that wasn't kang
you can clearly read the inscription on the floor
it reads omnia tempus enum semper in latin that
reads for all time always you probably could have
guessed that without being able to read latin
you also see a much more detailed pattern of
the phases of the moon that's etched into the
floor and in the concept art you can see what
this room was meant to be it's basically the
inside of a giant clock like this giant clock
structure that was meant to be up above this
but it basically means the entire citadel
itself is meant to feel like a giant clock
like they're walking into a giant clock which
makes sense that time is such a huge metaphor
for he who remains so he just begged that into
the idea of the construction of the citadel itself
the citadel itself became a giant celestial clock
so to speak if you remember the giant statues seen
in the entryway chamber that have the clocks for
faces they refer to those as the sentinels of time
they didn't say whether or not they're meant to be
actual creations of he who remains or if they're
just artistic expression like metaphors you
don't really get a solid close-up of everything
on his shelves but you do see what look like a
lot of ancient egyptian artifacts behind them
when loki and sylvia are fighting which is yet
another rama tut easter egg for the very first
version of kang to debut in the comics like
the great sphinx or the great pyramid a lot
of you've also asked if we're going to see rama
tut show up during the eternals movie or there'll
be an easter egg for him because that's going to
cover the ancient history of the earth in the mcu
it's possible that they do have some minor easter
egg but i don't think that jonathan majors was
supposed to have a cameo during the eternals movie
so if we see a really big ramat kang easter egg
it might be during the moon night series next year
because that trades so heavily on egyptian history
so if you spotted any of the big easter eggs that
i didn't talk about during the video or my last
couple of kang videos just write them below in
the comments or if you have any big questions
about what's going on with the upcoming marvel
phase 4 movies or the other disney plus series
the marvel what if episodes are going to start in
a couple weeks i will be doing full episode videos
for that and that's meant to build on a lot of
this multiverse craziness that they set up at the
end of loki there's also supposed to be a couple
trailers coming in the next couple of weeks too
so whenever those get released of course i'll do
videos for them everyone click here for more loki
deleted scenes and to learn about the alternate
ending from the finale and click here for all my
loki episode videos thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!